so I want to thank the organizers for
inviting me back for us I can't rip this
semester so like all of you I think that
a lot of the most interesting things
happening both in computer science and
in physics right now are at this
interface so I also think that you know
we've we've all seen proofs that consist
mostly just of controlling error terms
and dotting T's and crossing eyes and
certifying things that we already knew
were true and then we've seen other
proofs that really seemed to illuminate
why things are true so in other words
proofs not merely as certificates of
truth but as one of the instruments we
use to figure out what the truth is and
I think one reason why i like this field
is i think most of the proofs we see are
in the second category ok so this i'm
going to present joint work with jess
banks who you should be overjoyed to
know is joining the math department here
this fall as a graduate student and Joe
Nieman and praneeth Metro poly um if I
have time at the end I will also show
some work with jess and on Roman bear
Shannon and jamming to and but a lot of
this has grown out of this larger
collaboration that florent told us about
this morning with with him and lenka and
a a sort of cast of thousands who've
been working on the the clustering
problem so also Katerina do bacho their
student tebow the sphere Jess again and
with lots of good advice from other
people so um so first of all I want to
redraw that picture that we saw a couple
of times this morning and where first
you have a lot of solutions
and then the solutions break up into
clusters oh yeah okay will that help
wake you up and so then there's this
position called condensation we heard
about and above here as we heard from
from Alan and Nike at this point on one
of these clusters kind of dominates
things become sort of more chaotic at
that point because what matters is the
few largest clusters rather than a
typical one and then in constraint
satisfaction problems then we hit the
satisfiability transition at some point
and everything disappears but in planted
problems something else happens because
there is actually a planted solution
which was built into the problem from
the beginning and so this is our
situation in statistical inference where
we assume that where did this problem
this graph or this data set or whatever
it is come from well we assume there's
some planted model where there is some
underlying ground truth or some
underlying signal which we're trying to
discover so in the community detection
problem it would be a partition of the
vertices into communities and the
clustering problem it would be a
partition of the points of the clusters
with maybe also information about where
the clusters are and we observe that
through some noisy channel um so here
and you know we heard about this earlier
today on this side of the problem the
you know things are so concentrated
around that true solution that the
problem becomes very easy to see where
where it is but down here you can't
actually tell what the planted solution
was um and in fact you can't even tell
the difference between this distribution
on and a null model where there is no
underlying signal at all on and so this
thing here is you know this conjectured
computational threshold above which some
spectral method or belief propagation or
something like that can hopefully be
proved to work but then there's this
information theoretic threshold that we
also heard about hunter on and that's
the same as condensation okay so the
idea is that to the left of this line
well it's true you have all these
clusters one of those clusters
corresponds to the ground truth but
actually all the clusters look pretty
much the same as each other and even if
I showed them all to you would have no
ability to tell which one corresponds to
the ground truth whereas to the right of
this line on you could really you can
really tell because this cluster will
actually be for instance bigger in the
planted model and in the null model and
we saw a graph of this on in Alan's talk
for instance where the free energy on
below this point is the same in the two
models and above that point there's a
higher free energy in the planted model
because there are more solutions because
there is a solution built into the
problem all right so um good so now to
make all this more concrete let me
remind you of some of these models which
some of you know very well but you know
for the folks at home on YouTube um so
let's talk about
the stochastic block model so this goes
back to the 1980s in the sociology
community it was rediscovered multiple
times some people call it the in
homogeneous random graph and in computer
science is popular to call it the
planted partition model on so we have n
vertices and we have K types of vertices
or groups or communities or blocks and I
will work in the regime where K is order
1 and then there is some K by K matrix
telling us the probability that a given
pair of vertices of this type in that
type are connected and on I'm going to
be working in the sparse regime where
this probability is on C sub the type of
you sorry about the double subscript
comma the type of V over m where c is
this K by K matrix on a very popular
special case is where C sub RS is CN if
R equals s and C out if R is different
from s 0 1 1 probability for connecting
with others in the same group as you
another typically lower probability for
connecting to people in the other group
and on so this labeling here which is
you know this map from the set of
vertices to the set of types is the
ground truth that we're trying to
discover in this case um so the game is
that someone nature or God chooses this
labeling then generates the graph
according to this model then shows you
just the graph without any of the labels
there are many other games we can play
we can show you some of the labels and
so on
um I will focus on the case where for
some reason we do actually know these
parameters learning those parameters is
another interesting problem i'll assume
that you know the number of groups ditto
and then your goal is to to label those
nodes and to come up with a something
which guess as many of possible many
labels correct as possible so on we can
we can imagine various priors but let's
assume that the labelings are all
equally likely so then this is the total
probability of seeing a certain graph
which is they're called capital X but
maybe later I'll call it G all right so
the null model here that we would like
to distinguish from is where we just
have an error any graph so so q Q of G
would just be orders r any where see n
equals C out and whether really are no
communities at all so while we're at it
let's just write down the average degree
so the total number of neighbors you
have in the whole world in expectation
um and now I also really like
parameterizing sort of the strength of
the community structure in the following
way I will call lambda CN minus C out /
k times the average degree and why do I
like putting it that way well if you
take this matrix which has CN on the
diagonal and see out off the diagonal
and you add up the columns you get this
which is K times the average degree so
if we divide by K times the average
degree we get a doubly stochastic matrix
and with this value of lambda this
doubly stochastic matrix is lambda times
the identity plus 1 minus lambda times
the flat matrix I like to call the
matrix of all one's cap
LJ so this is the matrix for everything
is 1 over K so another way to put this
is if I'm in a given group and I don't
tell you anything else besides the fact
that you and I are connected then this
is the transition matrix for telling you
the probability distribution of your
groups lambda is the probability that
you're in the same group is me and then
1 minus lambda is a probability that
you're completely independent of me so
it's sort of the probability that
information gets transmitted along that
noisy channel um I should mention that
you know one special case of this that
some of us have thought about is the
planted coloring problem where you're
completely not allowed to connect to
others in the same group assocn equals
zero and in in that case on lambda is
minus 1 over K minus 1 so it's negative
things are dis assorted or heifer
affilliate or anti ferromagnetic as
opposed to a sorta Tavor homophilic or
ferromagnetic let's learn some new words
okay all right so again there are these
two basic problems so one is what you
might call the detection problem
although a more traditional name for it
would be a hypothesis testing problem so
which is tell whether the graph G is
drawn from P or two so tell me whether
there are actually in the communities
and then we can also talk about what is
variously called the reconstruction or
recovery problem or I'm sure it has
other names too which is find that
labeling now when computer scientists
and lots of other people first see this
they're a you know the typical reaction
is to say oh I want the maximum
likelihood estimator Sigma hat which
would be the one which maximizes the
probability
of getting that graph um and or if there
is a parameter we would call it the I
wish I didn't know what this stood for
maximum a posteriori um you know this is
one of these acronym Laden fields on and
when things are reasonably dense like an
average degree which is growing
logarithmically and n this is a fine
idea and in fact people like on bikal
and Chen and lots of other people
including a recent more recent work by a
babe and by Ron Hall have shown that you
know in certain regimes you can label
everyone correctly but in the really
sparse case where the average degree is
order 1 this is a bad idea bad bad bad
so you just don't actually want to view
this inference problem in this naive way
as an optimization problem and I learned
this from Lincoln florent you really
need to care about the entire posterior
distribution of the labeling given the
graph and for instance if you want to
maximize the number of nodes labeled
correctly you want to compute the
marginals of this distribution and not
just find the most likely case so you
know let's say that I give you magical
access to that entire distribution we're
going to throw computational complexity
to the winds the question then is how
much does that distribution tell you
about the ground truth so it could be
that that distribution looks like this
and that the ground truth is just one of
many you know local Optima it might not
even be a local optima and you would
have no way of telling which one of this
which one it is that would be like this
situation where yes there are clusters
but all the clusters look equally good
or it could be that it looks more like
this sure it might be bumpy but there's
some correlation between a typical draw
from the posterior and the ground truth
and so if you like we're trying to prove
upper and lower bounds on that
information theory
threshold on or if you prefer the
physics term on the condensation
threshold all right how are we going to
do this so I'm going to focus on showing
bounds on when we can do detection it is
intuitive that if you can't tell the
difference between the stochastic block
model and an artist Renny graph that you
if you can't tell whether communities
exist that you also can't label them
better than chance however are our
proofs that one of that the latter
follows from the former are not as
generic as we might like and in fact you
can come up with silly trivial cases
where you can't tell the difference
between the planted model and the null
model but if I promise you that the data
is drawn from the planted model then you
can tell the ground truth really easily
so the connection here is not totally as
clear as we would like on so I'll focus
on the detection problem all right so
our main tool is going to be the second
moment method the second limit method
rides again all right so so what are we
going to do well I'm given the graph
there's what people call the likelihood
ratio so there's the probability of that
graph and there's the probability of
getting that same graph in the null
model and you know so what do
statisticians do all the time at least
some of them I forget which whether this
is the Protestants or the Catholics in
statistics that's a little joke but you
can do this thing called likelihood
ratio testing where you would look at
some threshold so the question
intuitively though if this ratio isn't
actually very big or very small very
often then it's hard to tell these two
things apart and so indeed what we're
going to do is bound how much this ratio
varies
um so we're going to look at its
expectation in the case where the graph
is drawn from the planted model which if
you think about it is also its second
moment when it's drawn from the null
model because both of these are just the
sum over all graphs of P squared over q
so why is this enough to tell us
anything um well I think one nice reason
is to look at the the kullback leibler
divergence between the two so this is
the average of this ratio of the log of
this ratio and by Jensen's inequality
this is less than or equal to the log of
the average which is the same thing so
if this is it if this is order 1 then
this whole thing is order 1 which means
that if I drew the graph from the
planted model where there really are
communities versus the null model where
there aren't there would only be a
constant number of bits of huh that's
interesting and intuitively with only a
constant number of bits it would be hard
to get order n bits out of it and do and
get the labels but the other reason why
this is interesting is this notion of
contiguity on so if we have two families
of probability distributions on you know
objects of size n then we write whoops
we write this if if you have a family of
events called e
if the probability of those are in the
null model q is tending to 0 as n goes
to infinity contiguity means that it
also goes to 0 in NP so for instance if
you had a community detection algorithm
if it never says yes in the null model
it must also never say yes in the
planted model which means that it can't
get both things right with probability
tending to one okay now on what you
would really like to do is show that
this works going in both directions that
takes more work so the cell Nieminen
slide did that and I should mention I
don't I don't I should mention that I
also John praneeth did that in a in a
preprint which became one half of this
combined paper so with the small sub
graph conditioning method you can really
explain away a lot of the variance and
reveal that um you know really gain
insight into the structure of this
distribution and then reveal that in
fact this ratio is with high probability
finite as in bounded below infinity and
above zero with high probability and
then you have both directions so I'm
just going to focus on one direction
even though they were able to show for
the block model that whenever this
whenever the second moment bound holds
then that bi-directional continuity
holds as well all right if you've never
seen this notion before notice that it
is a much much weaker notion than saying
that these two distributions are close
in l1 distance or total total variation
distance indeed it could well be that
the null model looks like this and the
planted model looks like that or
something like that it's perfectly fine
if a given graph is twice as likely or
half as likely in one model as the other
on so they could be quite far apart in a
variation distance but you it's just
that this ratio roughly
speaking has to not go to 0 or infinity
all right so let me briefly show you the
proof that if the second moment is
bounded then this holds on it's just
koshi Schwartz so on POV is just the sum
p of G the indicator random variable for
E and let's rewrite that as the sum over
Q of P over Q times then indicator
random variable and then using koshi
Schwartz this is less than or equal to
the square root of the sum of Q times P
over Q squared which is our second
moment times the sum over Q of the
indicator random variable squared which
is the same thing and this is QA v so if
the second moment is bounded and QV is
tending to zero than POV must also tend
to zero so and I I don't know I just
want it i have to give shahril borden of
credit for showing us how simple this
was he did that at a nice tutorial at a
workshop in Santa Fe last December all
right so now we can just try to bound
the second moment
but we got to have lots of fun doing
that I
there's some optimization problem here
about keeping the population of markers
balanced between the two trays it's like
the city bike rental programs okay all
right let's see is there anything else
vital I wanted to say oh I just erased
some of the useful oh no there it is
okay all right son good on so again what
are we computing we're computing the
expectation when the graph is just an
artist Rena graph when is drawn
according to the null model of the
square of the expectation of the graph
in the planted model given the given
some ground truth which we don't know
sometimes this and so expanding this out
and reversing the order of the
expectations we can write this as the
expectation over all pairs of partitions
and then the expectation over the graph
of pfg given that versus Matt okay that
doesn't go any further um
all right good so let's expand this out
a little bit more so all of these
probabilities are just products over all
the edges so maybe it's worth writing
down over here that the probability of G
given a partition is just the product
over the edges of the probability that
those edges are there is a probability
over the non edges of the probability
that they're not lots of you have seen
this before um good so then what do we
get here we get the product over all of
the edges of the expectation of either C
sub Sigma u sigma v c sub how you how v
over c squared that's if there is an
edge between them vs. 1 minus this one
with the Sigma's 1 minus this one with
the Tau's and then 1 minus C squared and
that's if they're not
so I'll let you do the next line or two
on but when and is large of course we
can turn so since these are all
independent this is a product and then
we can turn that into an exponential of
a sum and it will depend on how much
Sigmund how have in common is always so
let us define an overlap matrix so I'll
say a Zeta sub RS is the number of
vertices which are in group are
according to Sigma and in group s
according to tau if i divide by n over K
then if I assume for simplicity that the
partitions are balanced with n over K
vertices in each group which is not a
big deal then this is a doubly
stochastic matrix and then when I plug
that in here can I write on that no I
can't what only affected so good yes all
right it's the erasing that's the
problem okay okay Chris I think Alistair
really not
okay anyway um the punchline is that by
something we can sum over a let's say
well so this will be the expectation
over these pairs of partitions of e to
the lambda squared where that's this
eigen value of the parameter matrix the
block model times the average degree
times n over 2 times the Frobenius norm
sum of the squares of the entries the
Frobenius norm squared of the overlap
matrix okay so that's just two lines
yeah if the partitions are not balanced
the cut their contribution is actually
little old exponentially lows and rice
they don't know I mean you have to make
a little argument here and um uh yeah we
really need to talk about that later
great work if at all all right all right
so um so now we're going to change this
expectation into an integral over all
doubly stochastic matrices all possible
values of of this overlap matrix and the
question then is how many pairs of
partitions have a particular overlap
matrix and that is
this thing I will call the entropy of
Zeta where that's simply the average
entropy of a row of Zeta recall that
Zeta is doubly stochastic so each row is
a probability distribution and then
there's a factor of log K because you
know we're averaging over essentially k
to the N squared partitions ignoring the
sub exponential terms coming from
whether they're balanced or not and then
we have this lambda squared B over 2
times for Venus normalize one all right
good well so this is a lovely integral
how do we want to uh how do we want to
compute this and let's see what did we
want anyway what we want is for this
whole thing to be ordered one this is
our second moment we want it to be
bounded so let's pause and look at this
integral for a moment well suppose that
Xena was the matrix of where 1 over K 1
over K everywhere the matrix of all ones
/ k in other words supposed Sigma and
tau these two partitions and decay
groups were completely uncorrelated with
each other if I suppose those were the
pairs which contributed the most to this
integral well then everything would be
great because this entropy would be
logged k and that would cancel this and
the Frobenius norm squared of this
matrix is 1 so the whole thing would be
0 and this would be little o of 1 and
yes the polynomial term is miraculously
work out when you do this so what we
would like is for this whole function we
want this to be maximized by zeta equals
this flat matrix and lots of you know
this the point is that the second moment
works when the pairs of objects that
were counting that contribute most of
the second moment act like independently
chosen pairs if it's maximized somewhere
else than there though all these
correlations correlations mean variance
variance means the second moment method
fails then this would be something
exponentially large all right well so
when we saw this we had a glimmer of
recognition because this is almost
exactly the same as what you get when
you try to prove a second moment lower
bound on the K color ability threshold
and random dress
and on when you first look at this
problem you say okay well i know that
maximizing a function overall doubly
stochastic matrices that's a high
dimensional space but give me a break
surely this maximum is achieved by
something in a one-parameter family
rather like that one parameter family
something times the identity plus 1
minus that something times the flat
matrix I mean come on so I mean that you
know the trade-off of course is that the
flat matrix maximizes the entropy but
the identity matrix maximizes the
Frobenius norm every several years I
spend several months trying to prove
this put me out of my misery prove prove
that if we fix the Frobenius norm of a
doubly stochastic matrix then the
entropy of its Rose is maximized by
something in this one parameter family
or vice versa because then this would be
a one-dimensional calculus problem and
lots of things would be easier well if
you don't feel like doing that instead
you can do what a Clio piss in the or
did which is they said all right this
problem seems kind of surprisingly hard
I'm happy to tell you my sufferings if
you want to hear about them um so
instead they said let's let's get an
upper bound on this by solving a relaxed
problem let's maximize overall singly
stochastic matrices instead of doubly
stochastic ones so now of course we'd
have independent constraints on the rose
um they still needed lots of quite
clever arguments but it is easier and
what they showed is that this works as
long as this coefficient here lambda
squared d is less than or equal to twice
log K minus one
over K minus 1 and in case you think
that they gave up too much by that by
relaxing to single a stochastic matrices
the most you could gain by really doing
it if this was true is changing these k
minus ones to k's so it turns out this
is actually pretty tight when K is large
so good what we have proved now is a
lower bound on the condensation
threshold / the information theoretic
detectability threshold of well of this
and why is this nice well I neglected to
tell you before where the where the easy
hard threshold is so on this problem I
think has a nice recent history so in
this paper by de sel and me and lenka
and is dead we conjectured on that this
problem got easy when this crust one
which is also the khest'n stigand bound
or the bound for robust reconstruction
on trees this was then proved by nacelle
neiman and sly 4k groups just recently
for a larger group for larger numbers of
groups it was I guess he only has four
letters anyway so on by a bee and sand
on the negative side for two groups that
below there you can't do anything was by
Michelle Neiman's lie and independently
masuleh a there's also a spectral method
based on this thing called the non
backtracking matrix which was written by
lots of us
and then was proved just this past year
by Borden of and large and massilia
interesting that it takes more people to
conjecture things than to prove them I
think that's because you need to do some
experiments on anyway so for two groups
everything is known now but what what
this shows on for at least four okay all
right this is a lower bound I'm not
going to show you the upper bound
because it's too easy so the upper bound
is just a first moment argument showing
that above a certain point with high
probability the only partitions that are
roughly as good as you would expect the
ground truth to be are in fact
correlated with the ground truth that's
an easier argument um and for a certain
regime of lambda it's within a constant
of this so you should view this as theta
of log K over K and so what is this show
it shows that for sufficiently large
number of groups indeed the information
theoretic threshold is below this
captain's dig'em bound where belief
propagation and spectra algorithms work
I should mention that the upper bound
part of this argument was also
independently obtained by of a and sent
on but not this lower amount um good so
that's my time but I just wanted to
mention that you can carry out this
whole thing as well for the clustering
problem which was one of the problems
that floor on talked about today so on
let me just define it and then I'll end
so let's say that you have K clusters
of n points in n dimensions and this is
this nice we're interested in this nice
sparse regime where m / n is some
constant okay so some people like to
call this the big data limit so in many
cases big data is actually not very big
/ variable okay so / / coordinate we
actually have not so many points um and
then you know these clusters are located
at various vectors which are safe shows
and randomly and then for each point you
choose randomly apart it you know you
choose a partition Sigma tell you which
cluster each point belongs to and then
you add Gaussian noise everything and
the interesting regime is where the
Gaussian noise has variants one per
coordinate so the the size of the noise
vector is typically root in but the
separation between these clusters is
only order one ok so the clusters
overlap a lot so analogous to the sparse
block model we have no hope of labeling
every every point correctly we can only
hope to do better than chance and here
we can again show that when there's a
sufficiently large number of clusters
the information theoretic threshold is
strictly below the threshold at which
spectral algorithms like PCA work um and
that is the work so yeah so this stuff
with Jess and Joe and beneath just got
accepted to cult and this stuff about
clustering with Jess and Roman and
gemming I'm sure will be accepted
somewhere wonderful
all right thank you very much mr. shop
where the algorithm works is it where it
starts to not work will start moving to
moving up so if this is bigger than one
then belief propagation does better than
chance on and we believe indeed it is
optimal and I but we don't quite know
that yet right on anyway but you know we
strongly believe that in fact it is it
is optimal that nothing can achieve a
higher accuracy and a higher fraction of
nodes labeled correctly I drew the
bigger the order I thought that I
thought I just saw the ma KO locating is
the information theoretically all right
this this is the information theoretic
threshold but you know the we don't have
an algorithm but what we would do is
exhaustive search you know look at all
partitions I guess I'm not sure their
children by its optimal if it's what I
mean then hello yeah sorry right okay
yes above this point we think that
belief propagation is Bayes optimal that
achieves the you know the highest
accuracy just as high an accuracy as you
would get if you could magically sample
the entire posterior so below this point
and you know Florence showed us this as
well I mean what's going on is that ok
so for two groups everything looks like
this here's belief propagation and below
here nothing works information
theoretically ok so that's what Michelle
Newman and sly should on for a larger
number of groups and larger here is like
five what happens is when it's easy
belief propagation starting with random
initial messages goes there but it has a
discontinuity
because what's really going on is then
there's this regime where there are two
competing fixed points the one where
everybody is equally likely to be in
every group on but and the one where you
would stay near if you magically started
at the ground truth the problem is that
this one has a very small basin of
attraction so in physical terms there
seems to be a free energy barrier
between these two things um then the
condensation point is the point above
which if I actually showed you both of
these fixed points then as a good
Bayesian you would choose this one below
this one there's actually exponentially
many other fixed points that aren't
accurate that look equally good okay so
that's the point where yes there are
clusters but they all look equally
convincing um so it depends what you
mean by belief propagation if you had
time to explore the exponentially large
space you would eventually find this
fixed point as well but if you start
from random initial conditions most of
the time you won't see it
what elevation
let's thanks again the grease